[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by ali lee kravaglio
aka aj in the new rom-com crush which is
on hulu now how you doing today i'm so
good how are you
i'm doing great i'm so excited to be
joined by you um i absolutely love this
film i think this is going to be one of
those rom-coms that stays and people
play forever and every watch it's so
much fun and it's really really strong
and obviously you have a great
performance in it now were you always
going to play aj in this film
yes i was um i it was it was offered
like if i wanted to audition for paige
but i i knew i wanted to
lend my voice to aj because she was so
different than anything i had
any woman i had ever played before um so
yeah i always knew
okay cool so was there a part two that
do you know if it was like something
you'd audition for or was it planned out
the part for you was it written for you
no no no no i'm definitely auditioned
for her
i remember reading the script and then
getting the sides and then going um and
having a
meeting with the director and talking
about
aj and
basically i my favorite part about
auditioning is doing the homework of of
kind of like
what do i like to eat why am i saying
this line like you know kind of just the
back story behind the character and so
speaking to sami cohen our director was
really helpful because i i was also i
was also like i don't know she just
she feels really like emotional and
place things close to her chest like i
think that she's a scorpio and i
remember sammy being like
oh i'm a scorpio so that checks out and
i thought that was very funny and um but
yeah i always knew i wanted to play aj
um i loved her
physical strengths i loved that she was
seemingly like a perfectionist and she
never wanted to run her up she worked
very hard on track and very hard in
school
and also juxtaposed next to gabriella
who is her sister who is seemingly
perfect you know there were just so many
traits about aj that just left me like
yearning i was like oh i just i i want
to i want to play her please let me and
thankfully thank you
thankfully you did and he killed it and
also what i'm interested to know too is
this film gets so much right in the
queer rom-com area where that can get
messed up a lot now
you do you have any particular things
you think like what is the key to avoid
like a pitfall like what what would be a
pitfall to you seeing other kind of
queer rom-coms that have kind of dropped
the ball you think um
i think okay let me tell you what i
think
um like makes a good rom-com how about
okay
i
there's got to be
the slow burn to to the kiss there's got
to be an epic kiss
yes um
there have there is always some type of
miscommunication
that
sets the the two
characters on different trails
um and then it also has to be funny you
know so with that formula in place i
think crush
knocks it out of the park um our humor
is
so
so on the nose i absolutely loved that i
remember when i read the script i was
like this is so
gen z like
it gets very honest and open and
sex positive as well um
yeah i i'm very proud of our rom-com no
and it definitely hits all those things
you mentioned i also think it hits too
is the chemistry of its leads is like
off the charts so does that
you know is that something that you
can't control it just happens or it
doesn't or can you actually work at that
um i think you can work at it uh i think
it i mean it speaks to
to being a good actor you know what i
mean like i worked very hard with rowan
to
like perfect those scenes and with sammy
as well sammy cohen our director
like it's the slow burn you know what i
mean so it's about slowly building up
their relationship
and my favorite scene between the two
characters paige and aj is
when um
we're side by side and we're talking
about
how it felt and what it meant to
come out to our families as well as what
it feels like for myself to be
constantly compared to my like
sister who is seemingly perfect and
always standing in the shadow and um
like it's these conversations that take
it from a first crush to a first love
and that was really beautiful to
to figure out and to find
yeah and there is a lot of beautiful
moments in this and like you mentioned
too there's a lot of really funny
moments which i love but i think that's
also very honest too like because we all
experienced that in high school so was
it surreal to you to jump back to your
high school days and was there any maybe
moments in particular maybe on set or in
scenes that really felt like somewhere
you'd been before
um
i mean as soon as you step back into a
high school you're like oh god i'm
surrounded by lockers and then once it
happened
um we had fantastic background to most
were native to syracuse new york where
we were filming i was like oh suddenly
i smell body odor and i'm right back you
know what i mean like once the hallways
are packed and you have to push your way
into like to get to the next class
you're in it yeah so that was really fun
uh
yeah and and to play a high schooler
like i
it comes naturally to me you know like
i'm 21 but
my high school experience was
i suppose very different from what other
peoples were like i finished my high
school online i received my diploma from
my school but i also went to an all
hawaiian school before getting pulled
out to finish
um like the press tour for moana which
you know like derailed my my normal
schooling process so i think whenever i
play a high school character i'm always
like i i cherish it a little bit i'm
like ah remember when all i had to do
was go to class you know like i didn't
quite appreciate it when i was there but
through through my characters i get to
relive it over and over and over again
that's awesome i guess that's the beauty
of acting in a sense too and you just
mentioned moana too and i have to bring
up it's my nephew's favorite film so
this is like exciting for me talking to
you for him and
i have to ask too do you still pinch
yourself from time to time that you are
a disney princess is that something that
like do you think about that a lot is it
just you i
i really don't think about it you know
like i don't exist like this i i'm very
like i
i mean i'm i'm from hawaii like born and
raised in hawaii i
like watching studio ghibli films
they're my comfort movies like i just
don't think of myself as a like a disney
princess you know like i don't really
watch moana over and over like like some
other nephew might
always like it it warms my heart to know
that i'm like making an impact and the
film came out in 2016 you know when i
was 16
so for me
it was
incredible but i also
i was like what's next do i still get to
be in this industry or am i a one-hit
wonder you know
right
to look back on it is is very special
but in the moment i i couldn't have
fathomed how how far it would take me
and speaking how far things will take
you how far i'll go hit one billion
views on youtube which you had shared on
instagram which is incredible
is that
but that that's also such tribute to how
great of a singer you are so
i wonder is singing or acting the true
love or is it equal in your eyes like do
you kind of have a preference
it's so hard to say um
i've always been singing always been
singing when i was
younger i
sang in church choir and in concert glee
singing comes easy to me
and that's like it's it's a god-given
talent like it's something that i love
but it's also something that
i
i don't take notes on very well you know
what i mean like i like i don't want
people to be criticizing my singing or
to be criticizing my because i write as
well but like
these are mine like this is mine
whereas acting i can take a step back
because that's a character you know and
i'm receiving a note to play a character
better whereas my lyrics and my music
come straight from my soul so that's my
baby i i love both of them but they're
completely different um completely
different beasts
totally and that's a great answer and a
beautiful answer and i'm happy to see
you do both and that you crush it at
both now the elephant the room i have to
ask on march 6 you tweeted say no to
mayonnaise that is a hugely
controversial statement okay
what is your beef with mayo
um
i don't like it
also
also i have a specific beef
because
i get called aioli sometimes
and instead they call me aioli and that
pisses me off so you know what
they know what a man is join in on it i
still know what i said
wow i think you might have converted me
to that i will i will stop putting mayo
in my tuna thank you
um everybody check out
aolili
crush it on crush
on hulu now
thank you so much for joining me today
and i hope to talk to you in the future
thank you me too have a great day